We know the z score, so we can find the probability of getting anything less
than that z score using our z table. So here's 0.8 and here's the column where
it intersects 0.04. So the probability of getting less than a mean of 40 is
0.7995. So the probability of getting greater than a mean of 40 is 1 minus
0.7995, which is only about 0.2. So it's somewhat unlikely to have randomly
drawn a sample from the whole Klout population with a mean of 40. If this mean
wasn't selected by chance, then it's possible that this app, the Bieber Tweeter,
which automatically re-tweets Justin Bieber, could have played a role in
increasing these people's Klout scores. But how unlikely is a probability of
0.2? There's no set threshold. But in the next lesson, we're going to show you
how statisticians have formally decided whether or not something is likely or
unlikely.